je suis arrivé donc j'avais 17 ans donc
on m'a dit sur les petites choses on a
j'ai fait un essai et donc après tout a
été bien et j'ai continué voilà plus de
travail je sais pratiquement parker un
pantalon je le sais d'oise
voilà cette couturière chevronné est
l'une des 18 salariés de l'entreprise le
laboureur c'est le laboureur nous
produisons essentiellement du vêtement
de travail et du vêtement de travail qui
est à destination principalement des
charpentiers découvreur des menuisiers
notamment dans le système du
compagnonnage vu son âge on se doute que
jean cau pleutre ne dirige pas le
laboureur depuis très longtemps
cette entreprise il l'a racheté voici
deux ans mais l'histoire commence il ya
une dizaine d'années je travaillais chez
le compagnon j'étais menuisier au sein
d'une formation chez les compagnons
et puis j'avais un petit peu envie de
voir autre chose donc j'ai décidé de
faire un site internet qui pouvait
proposer à ces mêmes compagnons des
produits des larges au décolleté les
produits qu'ils portent habituellement
et ce de manière on va dire plus moderne
que ce qui existait auparavant
et puis chemin faisant monsieur est
l'anti partant à la retraite
on s'est un petit peu positionné et la
collaboration s'est toutefois c'est
somme toute bien passé et c'est comme ça
qu'on en est venu à reprendre
l'entreprise de monsieur démenti est ce
que ça vient du tissu de base ou est-ce
que c'est dans les dents fabrication
c'est long non ça je ne sais pas mais
les voici ensemble jean-charles les
lentilles l'ancien directeur de l'usiné
et celui à qui il a transmis les
vêtements qu'ils examinent montre bien
l'évolution de la production ces
dernières années au départ quand tu fais
rentrer c'est un vêtement de travail
donc j'étais juste pour les
interrupteurs enfin le voyez un genre de
vêtements assez simple pour moi j'ai
après au fil du temps lyon je me suis
rendu compte que c'était quand même du
travail assez joli c'est vrai les
couleurs
bien sûr il ya toujours les grands
classiques comme le large au le pantalon
de charpentier ou la veste d'ouvriers
noir baptisé le coltan sans parler de
toutes les combinaisons de travail mais
déjà sous l'ancienne direction le
laboureur s'est diversifiée avec de
nouveaux vêtements davantage orienté
loisirs comme ces vestes en laine plus
fantaisie cela dit les fondamentaux
restent les mêmes l'obsolescence
programmée n'est pas dans la culture
maison ici on fait solide et peu chers
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est que
les marques vont vouloir vendre un
maximum de produits le plus vite
possible pour que les gens renouvellent
leur garde-robe
il ya un déchet énorme qui est fait dans
le vêtement dans le monde en général
j'ai pas envie de dire que l'on va à
contre-courant mais effectivement
aujourd'hui la plupart des gens ont
envie de revenir à quelque chose de plus
simple
ce n'est pas un produit luxe c'est un
produit qu'on pourrait qualifier de haut
de gamme d'une part parce qu'il est fait
avec des matières de qualité et qu'il
est fabriqué avec soin en france mais
c'est pas un produit qui est inabordable
pourquoi parce que notre clientèle de
base l'utilisent pour le travail on n'a
pas affaire à des gens qui ont un
portefeuille trop garnis la réputation
de l'entreprise le savoir-faire des
couturières y est pour beaucoup
et le nouveau directeur s'en émerveille
chaque matin tous les jours quand je
vois ici les gens qui travaillent je me
demande un petit peu quelle magie finit
par opérer pour qu'on ait un vêtement
terminée alors j'essaie de
de m'adapter et tous les jours je veux
pas dans l'atelier et l'a récemment je
me mets à travailler avec chacun à un
poste pour pouvoir apprendre non pas les
ficelles du métier mais connaître un
petit peu quel est le parcours du
vêtement avant qu'ils sortent de nos
ateliers et le directeur n'est pas le
seul à apprendre des choses car le
laboureur n'attend pas des nouveaux
embauchés
qu'ils sachent déjà tout en arrivant à
la couture ce qu'on ne sait pas du tout
à fait novice j'ai tout appris ici à
proposer un cdi soit plus de 300
références 150 revendeurs des
exportations dans une douzaine de pays
de la nouvelle zélande au japon en
passant par l'allemagne les etats-unis
cette entreprise a su trouver son
créneau et s'y maintenir dans une région
qui a vu disparaître nombre
d'entreprises textiles la réussite du
laboureur est un petit miracle